you hear a message that's Ontario
significant given a respite dad who said
it just for a - man Yusuf San Francisco
is a sanctuary city but what does that
even mean it means that local police
aren't actively seeking out undocumented
immigrants in order to deport them
instead they're focused on fighting
crime in fact local laws require police
to ignore Isis detention requests unless
a person has been convicted of a serious
crime like murder rape or assault but
why would a city do this I firmly
believe it makes a safe safer or a
world-renowned city with a large
immigrant population we want to build
trust with that population and our
sanctuary City and other attendant laws
have allowed us to do that and building
trust with the immigrant community
police say helps them fight crime Kevin
Trudeau nurse - Veera cuando el contra
nadie meet accessibility Abba Hondo
yes in the course of positive Escrima
tendría produce eso ways he may use or
Cynthia Mae Coleman knows Vienna Claudia
estaba has lived undocumented in the Bay
Area for 15 years she's fought hard with
other activists to keep the city's
sanctuary laws in place alguna vez a
usted se sintió que vous llamar de
policía y ou cuando bivouacked la
violencia una persona de hombre blanco y
yo recorded ahead Cragen ammos tener un
derecho sarah scooches OC yo-yo ma la
policia yo ya may contain more pero the
el paso the city sanctuary laws were
first established in 1989 but in
response to mass deportations using
local police in 2013 city officials
passed an ordinance that reaffirms that
the police aren't Isis muscle recently
these laws have received a lot of heat
this month 32 year old Kate Steinle was
shot and killed at pier 14 by Juan
Francisco Lopez Sanchez he's an
undocumented immigrant who the SFPD
released back in April even though
one of him detained and deported Lopez
Sanchez who had already been deported
five times admitted to the shooting but
says that it was an accident still it
was enough to ignite a lot of
anti-immigrant rhetoric it's inexcusable
for San Francisco not to obey the law
sanctuary cities are wrong I joined with
my colleague Senator Tom cotton in
legislation that would bar any federal
funds from going to a city that it's
trying to define federal immigration
laws but you can have the mayor of San
Francisco arrested but immigrant rights
activists are calling for a sober debate
on sanctuary laws what's your response
to people who say that this is the
reason why there shouldn't be sanctuary
cities our community has consistently
carried fear and it's very present and
it's very real in our communities and
policies like the trust and in cities
are our sanctuary cities allow us to to
come out of the shadows and and seek
help when needed somos trabajadores
Somoza statista so most muchas cosas de
limpio Casas perilous we feel calm
professionally that somos Nikki knows no
nominee mercilessly